uh
seeing that it's uh one o'clock uh i'm
going to go ahead and open the hearing
on house bill
an act relative to the administration
and settlement of claims of abuse at the
youth development center and making an
appropriation therefore
this is a
a combined
committee hearing
because we found that the jurisdiction
belongs in in
probably two of our finance
subcommittees and so chairman emerick is
sitting to my left and uh and he has uh
the right to go ahead and interject any
time he wants
this is going to be
a
relatively
fluid session
because
i i understand this
uh to need to be a
a working session we have
this is a complicated bill
we want to spend 100 million dollars
that's a lot of money so we need to be
very sure of what we're doing
um so so we pr will probably end up
having at least one other working group
meeting later
is there anyone here representing the
attorney general's office
you are
all right we'll we'll get to you
um
now
um for
uh sort of a
social note um
representative rogers is is here
uh she
uh is is undergoing some treatment that
has
made her vulnerable particularly to the
coronavirus and so if we could maintain
social distance from her representative
walls
could you could would you have room to
move further away or are you okay the
all right no i just i just want to make
sure
that representative rogers controls her
personal space over there okay
all right very good
uh
so
um
with that
what am i forgetting representative
weiler to kick this thing off uh call
our first person up
from the ag
yeah
so why don't you come forward i i've
gone through this bill
in a lot of detail
and i have perhaps
20 or 25 questions so so i'm going to
let
others ask questions and keep track and
hopefully everything will get asked and
answered before we're through
before we get done though or get started
i i want to make sure i understand some
context and so i i'd like you to
correct me or validate what i'm what i
think is true
what what i think is true
is that
uh attorney general formella
has been intending to spend some time
with the claimants
and attorney who's representing a number
of the claimants
with the idea that they would sit down
and and try to make sure they understand
how this process ought to work
and that their
next meeting is on monday
and that after that monday meeting
it's entirely possible they may come to
some agreements that could cause us to
want to amend
1677. that that's my understanding could
you could you correct or clarify that
yes representative and
we need to know who you are for the
record i'm assistant attorney general
jennifer ramsey and uh general formula
may walk in at any moment uh he was
planning to be here but i know he has
governor and council today as well so
uh you are correct we have a meeting
scheduled monday with um plaintiff's
council
we've
been promised a
proposal from them
and we'll have a few days to review that
and then go through it with them our
goal is to try to resolve if not all of
their concerns as many of them as we can
so that if we come back to you in
another working session we'll have a
proposed language to recommend to you
that addresses hopefully as many of
those concerns as we can we've also
reached out to all of the other public
commenters at
last week's hearing
and we have uh one agreement with
respect to the right to know concern
that was raised and i have some language
that i can present to the group if they
want to see it today that will address
so that's that's good so you have
already some proposed language you'd
like to share with the committee i do
how would you like to do that do you
have copies to distribute and do you
want to
read it or go over the highlights i made
copies uh it is not
probably in the proper form
uh that you would like to see an
amendment but i i interliniated the
language that uh ms ordolano and i
talked about that that she indicated
would would satisfy her concerns
um
in the analysis section of the bill at
roman three
uh after the end of that sentence
we were proposing to insert the words
accept for settlement agreements
i'm sorry could you could you tell us
again where you're looking on the first
at roman three
uh at the end of the sentence we
proposed to insert the words accept for
and then
on the third to last page of the
document which is numbered page five at
down towards the bottom there is roman
and at the end of that section we
propose to add the language with the
exception of settlement agreements which
shall remain subject to rsa 91 a
roman 6
new sentence
pursuant to that provision settlement
agreements entered into between
claimants and the administrator will
remain available for public inspection
except that the personally identifying
information of the claimant shall be
redacted
so you're going to offer uh that in
writing so that i don't have to be a
very good scribe absolutely i brought
copies and i i think they went to the
back i think you all do
outstanding hole punches yeah
um
so then the last speaker was the the um
the coalition against uh sex sexual and
domestic violence and um i've also
reached out to them we also have
scheduled a meeting with them for next
week following the meeting with
plaintiff's council so at the end of the
week
anything we're able to agree to with
plaintiff's council will also be running
so so give me a timeline assuming that
um
that
synergy between these brilliant groups
will create new
knowledge
uh
one one might we
expect from that something written that
helps us understand what the the new
knowledge is and how it might affect
this bill
i would think that if not by the end of
next week certainly by the beginning of
the following week we would be able to
come
back to the committee with
some written suggestions for ways to
possibly amend the bill
we'll do it on any time frame you need
us to do
did you just say no later than one
february
i think it goes to the beginning of the
following week could you could you give
me a date please because i i don't do
math in my head well i'm struggling as
yep
i think monday the 7th sounds right it's
friday friday's the fourth i believe
yeah so monday the 7th
and then let me let me ask
the finance chair
if if we had a document amending
by the 10th of february is that too late
in the finance committee process it is
not
right
so madam chair i'd like to invite you to
come sit up at the table if you'd like
what you know whatever you want this is
this is a fairly informal
hearing
no no she's already i meant i meant like
up here
uh at the dinner table but uh
okay um
very good i so i think that timeline
works and and that and that you've
committed the attorney general to
7 february
okay that he's supposed to have all of
our statutes annotated updated
personally personally yeah
yeah so so you can sit up at the table
there if you want mr attorney general
what we just agreed to is that we
understand that you have a number of
critical working groups with a couple of
different constituencies
stakeholders and that um to the extent
that you come up with new awareness of
how this bill should be positioned
you'll have a proposed amendment to 1677
no later than close of business seven
february
is that a commitment you think you can
accept yes that sounds very workable to
me okay i apologize for being late i
just got out of governor and council
that's that's quite all right um
okay so the part that you miss that's
relevant to you is this is this is a
working group and we're expecting that
we're going to have other working group
sessions and so this is going to be more
informal than a traditional hearing
might be um and that everyone who has uh
questions or concerns we can enter into
a conversation as opposed to sort of the
standard
hearing q a i think because we have
members who have
co-sponsored this bill they may have
comments to make as well and i think
that's perfectly fine in a working group
environment
all right so i'm going to
open it up to the committee
and
i had
questions um
that was that i think may have just been
dealt with
and i discussed this with representative
lynn before the hearing
and my my general concern
do you need a moment to get organized
we're good i think we're okay thank you
okay uh was on uh page five
uh lines 28 through 31.
uh that's the section that basically
exempted uh records from the right to
know provisions
and and
is it rainy or reigns
ramsey
okay i yeah
attorney ramsey ramsey ramsey oh like
the god ramsey yeah okay good okay so ms
ramsay uh gave us um a verbal update and
passed paper around and i and i i guess
i'm gonna ask my questions anyways and
just have you tell me that the language
you've provided
fixes it or
or there's still an issue okay
um the questions i had was that we
we had a perception
that paragraph three
until or that section until you
corrected it
was probably a violation of article
eight of the new hampshire constitution
and then conflicted with the 2015
new hampshire doj guide for right to
know
and so uh so the two questions related
to that
was um right right to know settlements
or public info why did we want to exempt
them
and the other one was that the right to
know provides privacy protections
are those existing protections
insufficient
and so i think you must have considered
that and come up with some different
language could you just talk us through
what you were doing sure yeah i'll start
by addressing
the intent behind the language as it was
originally i think we were focusing our
thoughts on
trying to keep as much confidentiality
for victims as possible as they went
through the process so records of what
what did they say how did the interview
go
what were those exchanges like
um
we were not
i think we we that was our focus we were
not ever intending that
the dollar amounts and what the ultimate
result was would would not be public and
i think
that's where we can better balance to
your point representative the
requirements of the constitution article
one part eight um
or part one article eight sorry uh the
uh
the privacy protections that are already
provided for in 91a
i think
i think what we're intending with this
language is to balance those two things
so it the
the ultimate outcome of these
proceedings would be public how much
money was given but we would still be
able to protect the confidentiality of
victims you know their names and their
what happened leading up to the final
outcome
so i'm just spitballing here um
just take it as a brainstorming effort
yeah um
would there be value you think
in coming up with a
an example type of disclosure format
that you might use
using obviously fictitious data if you
need any data just so that that people
early on
can can can see
uh
how they're how we're going to know this
information what information you plan to
share is there any value in that
i think so yeah
showing a very basic example um i i do
know that
i think attorney ramsey has had
correspondence with with new hampshire
right to know
so we're working on addressing kind of
the specific concerns that have come out
of those communities but i i think there
would be value in that and we could
certainly do that it might be a very
basic template
but but to show an example of what what
would be disclosed
so to give folks a sense of whether they
think that's enough information or
whether only seeing that
still leaves more that should be
shared publicly
okay thank you for that is would it be
reasonable to expect that on the same
seven february timeline yes i think so
okay
thank you are to the folks at the
committee table and and the chair in the
background are are there any questions
that you'd like to review would you like
answered
is that one
does that work okay um i have a number
is this better
i have a number of questions and i think
um
you're doing but i'm just going to kind
of some of the things i hope that you
would
um in this document you're going to give
us on the seventh would be addressed
um
in it and they kind of fall under a few
things the first one that i wanted to
bring up is um
in the statement of purpose
um i would like to see
something stronger i know that i don't
want us to admit to anything that would
would um
in any way jeopardize any of the the
court actions and so forth that's coming
forward but i know my understanding in
dealing with victims in the past and
dealing with
some of the victim groups that are
representing them it's important that to
the victims that there'd be recognition
that there was wrong done
and i wondered if there's a way that we
can work language
into the statement of purpose
that um
that doesn't while it doesn't admit
guilt admits that there was something or
that the legislature recognized
that there was something wrong happening
over the last 50 some odd years
with
children that were put in our charge
um we had a
responsibility to protect people when
they're in our charge and in our care
and um and that didn't happen and so i'd
like to see if there's a way that
language and i'm willing to
work with anybody if i can be of any use
with it but a statement of purpose that
addresses that
so that there's some kind of statement
there that's um
recognition of the victims that this
wasn't the way we were meant to operate
but do it in such a way that we don't
make the state liable or any admissions
that would be a problem once it goes to
court do you think that that's something
that we could um
incorporate into this
yes representative i think that's
absolutely something we could work on
because i think we were initially you
know we're lawyers so we're going to be
cautious on that front but i think we
there's definitely some some room to
work on that okay because that's one
thing that i would very
important to me to have some statement
in there um the second thing comes into
um claim questions and i think this
might be something you're looking to
address is
broadening out from just sexual abuse
to
physical abuse and restraints and so
forth when they were used improperly and
traumatically to the victims and i know
that your hesitation on the physical
abuse was that
um
there are times that there might have
done for the safety or whatever but is
that that's one of the areas i presume
you're going to address with the um
document you're doing
yes i think we'll definitely be talking
about that with with the victim's
counsel um
one thing that i i should point out is
that the way the bill is drafted is it
doesn't
it doesn't leave out physical abuse in
the event that there's a victim who's
also suffered sexual abuse so if someone
has suffered sexual abuse
sort of additional physical abuse that
they've also suffered would be taken
into account i understand but there are
some people that had physical abuse but
um right it didn't come in to
qualify in the statutes for sexual abuse
yep yep okay yeah i just wanted to make
sure that was clarified but but yes we
we are going to talk about that uh okay
i do you know i think for the reasons i
articulated in the last hearing um
you know i do have some concerns some
pretty significant concerns with
broadening that definition but i think
for purposes of today it probably makes
sense for us to have those conversations
with with
the victims counsel who appeared at the
hearing last week and and have some more
discussion on that i think before
getting into that because it may be that
we can get to a place that that i think
would satisfy everyone and i'd
i'd appreciate the opportunity to do
some work on that before
before really
at the end of the day laying out to you
my final kind of strong recommendation
on what we do it's ultimately up to this
committee and up to the legislature of
course but i just wanted to enumerate
some of the concerns i had yeah that i
would hope would you just if mr chairman
said okay if i just continue or do you
want me to
okay
um
the other is a timeline question and
kind of classifying these is in the
timeline a few things first of all
um
the january 8 1980 deadline our date for
when claimants only people that were um
suffered anything after that i think a
number of us talked about that um and my
concern is somebody that was um
abused or suffered something
in 1960 or 1955 is still
suffering as much as someone later so um
is there a reason that we have to have a
date in there or can we leave it
that just anyone that's suffered
any abuse or anyone that that
is there do we have to have that 1980
date on there or can we just not have a
date at beginning yep we certainly don't
have to have it any date uh we
originally picked 1980 or
we came up with 1980 based on i think as
i said last week uh the best estimate at
least i could come up with based on what
i've seen through the criminal
investigation where a lot of these
allegations have centered
but
i think even just from a recommendation
standpoint from my perspective we should
talk about the date and then potentially
moving it or or eliminating it you know
the bill does
provide that it's only the person
themselves or if they're still alive but
incapacitated their representative who
can bring a claim
um so it's not it's not like estates of
decedents can can bring claims so
there's that provides a natural kind of
limit to how far back you would look
so i
anyway to answer your question yes i
think from our perspective from a
recommendation perspective definitely
room to look at that and that's
certainly an issue we plan on discussing
when we meet with attorney vicenzo
because i know that there's some support
for having no date and having the
limitations um in other ways if we could
also with the the timeline uh the
question of um
how long people have the year and i
think i addressed this to you before
just the year and i understand
compacting it but i think that um
some of us have some myself and some
other concern that that really limits
because um
a lot of these people have come forward
but a lot of them probably haven't
either and
some of them because of the nature of
this could be in penal institutions
could be in various places so that the
year deadline could be problematic so i
think um
some of us would like to see that
stretched a little bit longer and i'm
not sure the right time you know if it's
two years or three but one year seems
terribly short
absolutely and and again that i think
they're
you know that there's plenty of room to
have discussion around that i think i
think it makes sense to have a period
where there is a cut off date at some
point because it you know
i think we want to encourage folks who
at the end of the day will be willing to
come forward to come forward by a
certain date so the state at some point
has knowledge of the full scope of this
you know how many would potentially
participate in this process but i i
absolutely see your point that a year
might be too short
so
i think from my perspective that really
just comes down to to what the
legislature thinks is is the right
balance and we can have that discussion
again with attorney visanzo whose
victims counsel and
have that discussion with others so
representative rogers would you let me
interject here
that conversation triggered a couple of
thoughts and i can't keep two things in
my head for very long
um
on
on the on the one dealing with um the
one year window to file claims
i notice that there's language in there
that says
that the administrator
can return a claim if there's
insufficient information in the first
claim
and uh and
and it seemed like that could go a
couple of times where a claim could get
kicked back
it's not really clear to me what happens
to that uh one year timeline or deadline
if if if they haven't actually gotten
around to completing a claim
in that year
because of requested delays by the
administrator to get more information
does that extend the clock by
the amount that the administrator
requests it i i think that would be fair
but it's not in the language as i see it
yep i think and i'll let attorney ramsey
correct me if she if she disagrees i
think the intent would be that the the
year deadline is by which you'd have to
have made your submission
if the administrator then comes back and
asks for more information or feels that
there was something missing
you've you've gotten in the window at
that point so i i
we can make that certainly make that
clearer but i think the intent was that
it's not a year to get to the point
where the administrator feels like
you've submitted all the information you
have to submit it's a year to have filed
the claim in the first instance even if
additional information is requested
is that okay okay uh that that's great
i'm i'm just an old hospital
administrator i don't know how to read
these laws so i i appreciate that uh
then the other point
about
potentially
expanding the scope
so that the primary issue isn't is
beyond sexual abuse but may include
it just makes me wonder are these two
different statute of limitations issues
i i think the legislature passed a law
recently saying there is no statute of
limitations for sexual abuse and but i'd
but if if we include physical abuse in
the scope of what the claim can be
would that would that suggest a
different
um
date instead of 1980 for the physical
abuse claims so it wouldn't necessarily
suggest a different date than 1980 but i
think what you're getting at is that
there
there are
two separate statute limits there are
separate statute limitations issues with
with sexual abuse and physical abuse i
think at the end of the day this
this bill is essentially intended to
to waive relevant statutes of
limitations because you're going through
an alternative process you're not you're
not going to court so we're
we're not going to be looking as part
if someone files a claim
really what we'd be looking at is to see
whether they're allegations at least as
it's drafted were we're af you know
after 1980. um we're not going to be
looking to see whether there's a
separate statute of limitations in the
rsas that may or may not apply
but
so so but i i think you're raising a
point which is that
which is perhaps worth considering in
the discussion of whether to broaden
this to physical abuse is that you know
the legislature has has made certain uh
changes to statutes limitations for
sexual abuse that it has not done for
physical abuse and i think that that at
least reflects a a prior policy
recognition
that that sexual abuse is something that
um
that we want to take an even more
serious look at again not saying
physical abuse is a good thing or okay
but sexual abuse is a different category
uh thank you for that representative
rogers did you have more questions i'm
sorry i interrupted you i just wanted to
get those in thank you um
back to the timeline questions the other
um another one is um
is the
the the whole process is fairly
compacted as far as when the hearings
and so forth and i'm a little concerned
that it's so compacted and i think the
same reasoning that expanding the the
time that they can claim and so forth i
think that and i don't know if this is
one of the areas you wanted to address
with um plaintiff's counsel as well is
maybe broadening that out or losing it a
little bit because i worry that
everybody can meet all those timelines i
mean in a perfect world yes but i think
all of us that have practiced
in in a corridor in mediation find that
make quite often
the those type timelines are very
constricting so
yeah i think it's a great point i think
the intent of the drafting was to have
flexibility in there you know if you
couldn't meet a timeline um but but to
your point we want to make sure that
that's there because it as you say we
can aspire to meet very ambitious
timelines and then not meet them
we're
part of the compact timelines is really
is thinking about the victims and trying
you know especially some who if they
were harmed many many years ago to move
this process quickly i think that's
something they want to see but
but i think to your point representative
we wouldn't want to get so ambitious
that we we put people in a tough spot so
we'll we're
definitely we will take a look at that
okay
um
then i have a question about the next
category is the um
waiver of rights
and there's a number or a few places in
there where we talk about
um the claimant agrees to the
determination of the administrator and
the arbitrator is final and binding
whether or not any payment is there and
then after submitting a claim they waive
the right to seek any other
monetary relief in any form from the
state or its employees
um and i know i spoke to you about the
one of the employees and such and i
understand that most of them aren't
going to have a big pocket of funds but
as i said when i talked about the
statement of purpose to victims quite
often it's not the money that's
important it's the
acknowledgement
that there was wrongdoing there so some
of them might want to seek in a
particularly egregious i mean it's all
egregious but a few of them
the claimants might want to seek
individual action against an employee if
it was
action like that and i worry that we're
cutting them off from doing that by
saying they can't do any action about an
employee i know there's the it says
monetary relief but i just want to make
sure that that doesn't constrict them
that they can't go forward and file a
claim
um in in civil court if there's
something in particular as i said i
think they know they're not going to get
a large monetary settlement but
the acknowledgement that that particular
individual
um
did something to them and i know we were
pursuing criminal but there's also that
extra thing yeah we can absolutely look
at
look at that i think the intent
right is to is to
to sort of say you're waving additional
claims against the state to say this is
what the state's going to pay you but as
far as yeah the employees themselves we
can definitely take a look at that
and i think to your point i kind of hit
it last week some employees we will
pursue criminally there will be others
who are their allegations against and
because these cases are so old it's very
tough to build cases that you think you
can prove beyond a reasonable doubt so
there will be there will certainly be in
former employees who allegations have
been made against that we will not be
able to pursue okay criminally i
understand and um and kind of the last
thing when i talked about the um
back in the timeline and the whole thing
is the notice and if the notice is
adequate as far as just and i think this
was brought up in some testimony that
day
using newspapers and so forth as i think
i said earlier because of the nature of
this there's a possibility that some of
these folks might be in penal
institutions
um having graduated shall we say from
from this level um so i think that that
the notice needs to be stretched out a
little bit more and to maybe look at
that fact that where would these victims
be at to be not all of them are going to
be reading the newspapers to know about
it although we all think it's in the
news we should know
many of them because of the nature of
what they've been through
aren't going to be doing that so i think
that that needs to be broadened a little
bit from just the public media and if
there's ways to do it
um i'm sure you can figure it out but
i'm just worried it's too constricting
again yeah we can absolutely take a look
at that did you have a comment on that
um
if that's for the record could you speak
into the mic i'm i'm searching this is
this is being recorded i believe uh it's
being broadcast i also think it's being
recorded
mr ripple is is the recording of this
also going to be online for a while all
right
i was saying to the attorney general i
believe that this draft contains
language that we would also post it at
the at the department of corrections
that the process was going on
um if it doesn't we can certainly add
that
and i also heard a comment last time
about the possibility that we might want
to publish
on a broader scale than just within the
state of new hampshire and that was also
something that i had in my notes to to
contemplate as we work through this next
week thank you so i assume on the notice
that's fairly well established to what
constitutes legal notice and and so
i i would just expect we would follow
the
standard practice are you proposing that
we want to take the standard notice
practice and expand beyond that
that would be my suggestion because with
this case is is
different than what we usually do
and we are talking
a number of potential victims and a
large amount of money i think expanding
it to suit
um the nature of the victims here i
think it needs to be expanded a little
bit and i'm not talking about legal
notice i know we can we can fit those
bars but i'm talking about getting it
out so that people can know about it a
little further than what what we propose
but i think the department of
corrections is is a good start and i
think just pursuing it from there
thoughts mr attorney general
yeah i think it would make sense to go
go beyond necessarily what we would
typically consider to be adequate legal
notice because i
that that many times is not a very high
bar and so if we're if we're really
trying to make a proactive effort to
make sure the relevant population knows
about this i think it would make sense
obviously there are there are reasonable
limits to that but i think looking for
opportunities
um through which we can go above and
beyond what typically would be adequate
legal notice makes sense in this case
all right
so i want to i want to leverage off of
something representative rogers and you
were talking about earlier
you you mentioned that um
employees
during an investigation there may be
some indication that they've violated a
law along the way and that they might
also be subject to criminal referral if
you know depending on the facts and
circumstances yeah just to clarify
representative i i was thinking
specifically of the employees who were
alleged to have committed the abuse no
we're
okay that's what i mean okay
yes that we we currently have indicted
individuals who are former employees we
expect
that there will potentially be more
so can i share my thought on that sure
um
we specifically say that
the claims shall be submitted under oath
and the claimants who are believed to
have submitted false claims may be
referred to
okay so so should we have sort of mere
language that says employees who are
suspected of violating laws shall also
be referred to appropriate
law enforcement
because because it's silent on that but
you just said that we've already
indicted or you know arrested 11.
so i'm just for for fairness just trying
to get the balance that we're going to
treat nerdy well employees
appropriately yeah and we we would i
i can explain why that specific
provision is in there we we have had one
one former resident of of ydc or at
least one former person who claimed to
be a resident of ydc yes yes sir let me
let me cut you off there because i think
we're going to be agreeing on what
you're about to say yep
i'm actually talking about the flip side
i'm talking about adding a sentence to
say that the employee
could be subject to penalties
we say clem claimants can be subjected
to employees but we don't say anything
about the employees so
i think ms ramsey understands what i'm
saying no i i understand what you're
saying
and i'm fine with that i think the point
i just wanted to make is that
i don't think anyone would without we
don't have to do anything to make make
an employee or a
former victim who gives false statements
potentially subject to criminal
penalties i think employees generally
know that that will be the case and i
think part of the intent here was to
make clear that
if if someone submits a claim it's under
oath it's false that they could be
referred for prosecution but i think it
would be fine to to have that in there
just to your point so that there's no
confusion
um
all right
representative rogers are you done i'm
done thank you very much all right if
you have anything else let me know um
are there any
other questions by the committee
uh representation
thank you mr chairman
nice to see you both today and thanks
for taking my question
as far as the appropriation the 100
million dollars in reading the
legislation i see that's to
also cover your expenses such as the
investigator the administrator
how much of an impact is this going to
have on your agency and
is that 100 million dollars it sounds
like a significant amount of money which
it is but
is there enough money there between the
settlement and the administration of
this
if you will uh mess i i assume that you
may need additional outside counsel and
so forth
yeah it's it's a great question
representative i think that
i don't know i know that's not the
greatest answer i i can't tell you as we
sit here today whether it will be enough
enough to cover
all of the claims that come in and all
of the additional administrative
expenses we were to incur
as the department of justice to
administer all of this
i think this this represents our our
best initial estimate as a number that
could cover it
i we would make every attempt to keep
our administrative expenses as
associated with this as low as possible
so that as much of this money
is going to claims as possible but i
i think there's i think the best answer
i give that there's a possibility it may
not be enough i think we won't
have a great sense of that until we or
we won't we won't start to know that for
sure
until we see all of the claims that that
come in and we get a real sense of how
many folks are participating in this
process because that that will affect
not only the amount we pay out in claims
it will affect how much it costs
to have
to to administer it
i can tell you though i think we will
spend a lot less money from a department
of justice perspective on this than we
would spend on defending all of these
cases in court
so should should the legislature
be confident
that
all of the accounting codes will get set
up within this fund
so that we can clearly differentiate and
potentially audit
the money spent for the bureaucracy
versus and i say that in a positive
loving way yeah yeah the doj bureaucracy
versus uh claimants yes if if some if we
were to enact this bill or
or
a version of this bill you could be 100
confident of that because i think
you know while the primary goal of this
is to
compensate victims and and
repair some of the damage that's been
done when when we're talking about any
taxpayer funds but particularly taxpayer
funds of this amount that type of
accounting and making sure there's
transparency and the ability to go back
in audit to make sure we can keep an eye
on how the money's being spent i think
that's critical so i think you can
absolutely be confident of that
okay so so uh representative umberger
has a question for you you want to use
the mic ma'am
uh thank you
i just want to make sure that
are you suggesting
that the 100 million will only cover
this process
or will that include
um
people that choose to go to court for
settlement
i
i think
in my mind 100 million is intended to
to only cover this process but that's
that's because i think that the goal of
this is to have just about everyone come
through this process
if if
only half do and half go to court
you know what
what what i could see happening is that
we don't spend anywhere close to the 100
million on this process and at that
point we may come back to the
legislature and recommend that
some part of this money be because it
won't be needed for this settlement
process be used
for litigation in court
does that answer your question thank you
okay
uh i i'm sorry i don't see your name
thank you mr chair
i hate to belabor this but last week we
heard testimony from
an attorney that has 441
individuals
that will be part of a suit
and giving that number and giving the
100 million and giving the
this is finance the math isn't working
for me with 100 million i i mean i
certainly
appreciate and encourage to be
conservative on the front end of
something but
given this circumstance i think we'd be
better served if we had as
i don't even know if it's possible uh uh
as a realistic as possible number to
start with does that am i making sense
i'm just concerned that
maybe we're a little too low on the bar
or is that is there a purpose for that
that's all thank you thank you mr chair
yeah it's it's a really good question
representative and trust me we i we
we've wrestled with that there there's a
couple of pieces of this to keep in mind
again there's there's a difficulty in
predicting how many will come through
the process there
i think we have to allow for the
possibility that there will be some
folks who might come through the process
and get very little if no money because
we part of this is designed to to be a
claims verification process and when we
actually are able to
take a look at what some folks might be
saying
or take a look at the events some folks
might be saying happened we may find
that there's just no information there's
just no information that verifies that
the records don't support it the records
don't support the dates or anywhere
close to the dates
and so it's just
until we have a chance to start looking
at that it's it's difficult but but i
think you're raising a point which is a
good one that you know we should not
assume this hundred million will be it
and enough
but
because we've set it up in such a way
that claims can be paid over time
that
um
that there is a there's a claims
verification process we don't know how
many will come through i i feel fairly
confident saying a hundred million will
i don't i don't think you're on
how about now yes okay um if so there's
a waiver process in here and i'm trying
to figure out when the waiver happens
so you just suggested that some claimant
may come in
and there may not be enough evidence for
you to conclude with the evidence you
have available that you can prove how
that claimant was victimized
but if that claimant has to waive their
rights to even get you guys that far
that means that that claimant then if
i'm understanding the scroll he will
then not have the opportunity to go out
and hire a lawyer on his own and try and
prove it independently of what the state
is bringing forward on evidence am i
correct as to when the waiver happens
that they have to wait sign the waiver
only to have you guys say oh we we can't
find enough evidence and then
effectively deny them
the real bite at the apple by going to
court
well so
yeah at least as the bills drafted now
the waiver happens at the at the
beginning of the process so when they
enter the process
but if
the the process also provides that if if
there's a disagreement between the
administrator which would be
at least as the bill's drafted now a
designee of the attorney general if
there's a disagreement between the
administrator and
and the victim then it can go to
arbitration in front of an independent
arbitrator
so after all of the i mean
after all of that
if they go through the process they
the administrator doesn't feel there's
enough there to justify a claim and then
it goes to arbitration the arbitrator
doesn't feel there's enough there
i guess to answer your question yes
they it's a possible that there may not
be much if any compensation and yes they
will have waived their rights to go to
court
but but i think the reality is that if
that were to happen it means that if
they
then decided to go to court the chances
of being able to recover anything would
would
be close to non-existent
follow up
would that victim be represented by
council at the mediation level
so that i mean because depending on how
when council is in there and the role of
council would make a huge difference in
their ability to to prove or to show
their claim yep yeah no the victim would
be represented and i don't or at least i
i
given that we have 440 who are
represented and i would imagine anyone
who comes through this process would be
represented
so so i think the answer that is yes i
also just want to clarify you know i'm
not suggesting that i that i think there
will be
vic you know victims who come through
who don't get compensation i'm really
only suggesting that we don't know for
sure we when we when we we just have to
allow for that possibility and that's
one of the possibilities that was baked
into other factors that led us to the to
the to an estimate of a hundred million
dollars at least a best estimate of that
number for for the moment as we sit here
at a very early stage of this
will there be discovery available to the
claimants
i
i think
i'm gonna answer your question this way
you know what we're looking to do here
is to to verify a claim so it's not
it's not going to be an an adversarial
process i think that
we will
be
they will have access to any information
that we have access to that might lead
us to say we don't think
um
this claim should be paid
but i
but
they wouldn't have access to discovery
in the traditional sense
or the process wouldn't work that way
because it's not it's not going to be an
adversarial process so we're all we're
only we're going to look at
um
the best information we have they'll
they'll get access to that information
if they ask for something we will
we will give it to them if we have it
you know it's not um so
so i
i think the best way to answer your
question is sort of twofold
i wouldn't think of it as discovery
because it's going to be more of a
claims verification process than an
adversarial adversarial process but to
the extent there's a discovery analogy
in this process yes they will they will
they will get discovery but it wouldn't
work quite the same way as discovery and
in the traditional litigation sense
one more question
is it a follow-up to what you just asked
because i want to follow up to what you
just asked well this is going to be real
quick if you don't mind and that is does
the is there anything in this bill that
caps recovery at the 100 million that
we're doing or say that we end up with
300 million in claims can we still
proceed with 300 million in claims
yes we could still proceed with 300
million in claims the legislature would
need to appropriate additional funds but
yeah there's nothing in here that's
intended to have this be a cap it just
the it just isn't an open-ended
appropriation which i know i think the
legislature generally doesn't like but
it's it's uh i think it contemplates
potential additional appropriations down
the line i think it explicitly says the
administrator can ask for additional
money as needed so it's in there right
um so
as you were talking about uh sort of the
you know modified
discovery procedures that you're going
to use i don't recall reading anything
about the
claimant's ability to
make inquiries about state records to
help them fulfill
their claims
and and it and it sounds like
um something that you expect and you
believe to be rational and so makes me
wonder if if that a sentence or two
should be added into an amendment to
clarify
the claimant's ability to request state
records
so independently of this bill um
all of these individuals have the
ability to request their own records
through through the the ordinary process
that applies to
ydc and to uh dcyf and dhhs
and certainly a cross-reference in this
bill to those provisions
would would certainly i think help make
that more clear
this also contemplates adopting
guidelines by the administrator and i
think in those guidelines would be
another place to direct claimants um to
the places they could go for resources
to help document their claims i think
attorney general formula has it correct
though to say that the purpose of this
process is to try to verify claims if
possible
and that's uh that is in the bill at the
bottom of page three um so i i i'm not
sure what discovery
they would need but to the extent that
they were to ask the investigator to
help them to find something i think
that's contemplated by this
and could be uh made more clear either
in the bill or in the guidelines all
right and and what i'm looking for is is
not
not to have every rock turned over but i
i am just trying to make sure that we
have a bill that is perceived
by stakeholders as as being fair and
balanced
you know if we if we start with a a nice
fair and balanced
law
hopefully that will lead to a trust
relationship that's necessary to
negotiate all these cases so
that's that that's where i'm coming from
absolutely and i think those are great
suggestions
okay um so
so i i have more questions if there's
representative wallner you had a
question earlier do you still have one
okay
um
so i have a question of
i'm sorry where oh yeah go ahead
i'm sorry there's one other question
that i didn't ask you
um in this process we have um the
attorney general as being the
administrator
um and you're also a party to the
actions i wonder if there's any thought
given or any possibility of looking at
having a truly neutral not to say that
your office is not neutral but it's odd
to have a party to what the actions are
be the administrator as well
and essentially the neutral force
and i don't know where else we look so
i'm not suggesting exactly who
but um is that something that um you
thought about or is there a way to make
it truly neutral so it's not a party to
the actions
yeah i would think about it this way you
know the
this is a it's meant to be a settlement
process it's a unique settlement process
but but it's a settlement process so the
you know the attorney general
is
is has been for i mean we could go back
and look but i think for
most of history is in state history the
the authority who can settle cases on
behalf of the state
the way this process works the
administrator
you know takes in the claim and and does
a review and is
the first to maybe makes the first offer
on behalf of the state or is the first
line to
to make an offer to settle on behalf of
the state but then if the
you know if there's a disagreement it
does go there is a neutral actor here
the arbitrator is the neutral actor
i think the
the issue with having the administrator
be someone other than
the attorney general or the department
of justice is that then the state
doesn't really have a representative in
the
in the equation this is set up so that
you know the victim and their attorney
or are in the equation the administrator
is there on behalf of the state to do a
review and make an initial offer and
then the arbitrator is the neutral
if the administrator is also neutral you
have you have the victim who's a party
to the case you have a neutral
administrator so the state really isn't
represented
um by someone who's looking out for the
state and then you have another neutral
so i think it is something we've thought
about
because i
i can understand the initial reaction
that oh geez well the administrator is
the attorney general and the attorney
general's not neutral here the attorney
general represents the state but
i think as the administrator either i or
my designee would do the
you know do their best to look at this
objectively and come up with something
that they think is fair to the state
through objective standards and but we
would have that neutral arbitrator
that's the
the second layer of protection and i i
think that
from my perspective that that's the best
and most balanced way to address
the concerns and the need for for an
ultimate neutral decision maker but
certainly
i imagine the when we have discussions
with attorney visananzo and others i
imagine we're going to discuss this
issue more
thank you i'd like just to follow up i
want to return to the waiver because
something occurred to me as you're
speaking
what we're asking claimants to do is
waive their rights before we have any
idea
how the
our administrator is going to view their
claim
so if we have an administrator who
chooses to view the claims as
requiring
much smaller damages than
perhaps the claimants or their attorneys
or others would do certainly after the
first few claims are administered people
are going to get the idea and they're
not going to sign up and sign the waiver
but even those first few claims when
they come in when they have no idea how
the administrator is going to rule and
view their personal damages and the
effect on them for their
lifetimes i i'm still troubled by having
to sign this waiver before you know
anything that's going on and it's so
different to me
than traditional litigation and i'm
wondering if there's a way around this
to
not have them completely waive their
rights when you know you could have an
administrator that says fine you know
some of the some of these claims that
you gave us in in that spreadsheet of
how you came up with the money were to
me surprisingly small given the damages
that were done to those victims and the
more recent claims the damages are much
larger if we have a neutral evaluator
that's using those kinds of numbers that
were in the spreadsheet that you handed
out a week ago those claimants are going
to from my point of view be under
compensated and and they will have
waived their rights and there's no way
around it so i'm looking for a solution
here as to how these claimants don't
have to waive their rights before you
have some idea of how the neutral
evaluator is viewing the damages
i think one important piece of that that
gets to your concern representative are
the guidelines that that would have to
be developed and those guidelines part
of what they would
lay out
are are sort of how to value claims
um i talked about this a little bit last
week you know that
it's a little bit crass to be to to put
it bluntly and honestly but there's kind
of no way to
no way really to do this other than to
to assign a value to different forms of
abuse and that's partly what these
guidelines would do
so there
someone would only be coming into this
process once they see what those
guidelines
look like as we talked about last week
we would des we would intend to design
those in such a way that you know it
would lead to claims that that are
consistent with what
the app or consistent with the average
that we've found based on based on our
research but anyone who came into this
process would have notice of that they
would they would see those guidelines so
there would be some
there
at least on that front they would have
some notice on how the administrator is
going to be looking at these
claims
so i think that that should address part
of your concern
as to you know
when a waiver happens that i think
i can say sitting here today that's
something we're willing to continue to
think about and again i i imagine that
we're going to hear some more ideas on
perhaps how
how to have that work so i
i think in combination with the fact
that
this will all have to be based on
guidelines or at least
the guidelines will
will give an indication of how these
claims will be valued and the fact that
we
we can have some more discussion on that
point i mean that's how i would answer
your question sitting here
sitting here today because i see the
concern you know this is a very
i think this is just one component of
multiple components of this that are a
delicate balance trying to to be fair
but also
um
you know account for the obligation to
representative emerit
thank you
i'm going to talk in more general terms
because i'm not an attorney
but since i own my own business i
haven't woken up in the middle of night
so many times since i read this bill
and the and the caveat that was
suggested by
some testimony last week about not
having a ceiling
uh
basically you could bankrupt the state
i mean this process could bankrupt the
state it would if over here we're going
to do all these claims and i have
nothing
i'm not
negative on the claimants don't get me
wrong
they have rights to make the claim
we also have a responsibility to the
state
to not go bankrupt
so
hopefully part of the discussions
going forward is is to leave it to have
some ceiling if you want to raise the
ceiling
fine but i think there needs to be a
ceiling as part of this bill
uh at least
for
to have a bill
i don't think i could support something
that said well whatever happens happens
so i'm
i hope the ceiling stays in there in
some form even though it can be raised i
i understand that
the other thing is let me ask you a
question about that just to make sure i
understand it it currently says there's
a hundred million dollar appropriation
and that the administrator must come
back to ask for more is is that
inadequate no that's fine all i'm saying
is i just want to
arm you when you go to your next round
of discussions that it doesn't disappear
so it's a blank check so to speak the
other thing is i think timing wise and i
represent was mentioned earlier
once the gun fires
you're going to have you're going to get
swamped
we already know there's 400 plus
claimants
and you've got some things in here that
you're going to turn around in 90 days
uh and i think that was mentioned
earlier
i don't think you're going to be able to
handle it
i mean
you're you're getting
getting ready to by the time this gets
signed
you may have four months in order to get
all these things you're going to do done
um
until here come here it comes
and it's going to come in like a tidal
wave
because you know there's 400 and some
already standing in line
and when you start advertising that
number could go up so i don't know how
to buffer that for you
i mean
if you had some process that said we
will handle claims
as best we can in 90 days
but when the the level reaches some
number and i don't know what it is let's
say it's a hundred claims that the
process would automatically go to 180
days instead of 90 or something i i
don't have an answer for you i just have
a problem to give you
so
that those are my thoughts i i i just
want to
caution that
this is going to come in a very big lump
yep you know
i i i agree you know i i i think to your
first point i just want to assure you
i'm absolutely with you on on the the
ceiling concept and the fact that we
have to you know we have to this is all
about balancing the the you know the the
goal of doing
um providing some compensation but also
protecting protecting the state um and
which is ultimately protecting all of us
you know we we are the state at the end
of the day so so i'm with you on that i
don't think you need to worry that
that's gonna that's gonna disappear at
least from my perspective it's
ultimately up to you but but from my
perspective that would not disappear
from my recommendations um as far as the
timelines
one we are
not that we would ever assume you know
what the legislature would or were not
would not enact but we are preparing for
this even now in the event that this
gets enacted so thinking about what
guidelines would look like thinking
about how this would work so i we are
doing that i have the same
you know i'll i'll admit stress about
the timelines and and i think what we're
going to continue to try to do is
is balance the need to make sure this
moves quickly but not as i said to
representative
rogers not aspire or not be so ambitious
that
that um
this just goes off the rails so i think
we've we've tried to build some buffer
in there in some cases you know the
timelines
i think it's best efforts 90 days but it
could be more or but it could be another
90 days there are other points where
it has to be submitted to arbitration
within a certain amount of time but it
doesn't necessarily require that
arbitration has to then happen
within a set time so we've tried to
build some buffer in there but we will
continue to
to think about that and refine that
because i absolutely recognize that that
this is going to be a challenge you know
i i would
i would be lying to you if i sat here
and said nope
we will be able to do this easily this
will require a lot of hard work it will
be a challenge but i i am confident that
we're up to it and i'm confident that we
will
do an honest assessment of what outside
help we need and we'll go get it and we
can keep those costs as low as possible
but but we recognize that this will be
if the legislature enacts this bill that
this will be a very challenging process
for us to pull off but i i'm confident
we can do it and we will continue to
think of ways to
make it even more likely that we'll pull
it off
additional questions
okay so so i i like that training
thought and because it triggers uh
something i've been wanting to ask you
the the effective date on this is
september 1.
and and it seems to me
like uh you all are going to be
developing forms you're negotiating with
the stakeholders about this
you want to develop these guidelines
probably earlier in the process than
later
and then it refers to
the need for the administrator to be
able to delegate a completed claim to an
investigator to go look look into the
details
so
that that that implies a manpower issue
and perhaps because we're not doing this
work now you need new investigators
additional supplemental
folks
that you you you would have to begin the
hiring process about now if you're going
to have them in september right i'm just
guessing
so
all of that is a setup to ask the
question of
um
does this effective date need to be
sooner or do you are would you already
have the authority to spend money on all
of this stuff
before this effective date
what you know if you feel like you need
to start spending some money to get
ready to ramp up for this
when would you begin to spend that money
would you want it to have passed the
senate before you you started to ramp up
i'm just i'm curious about your timeline
yeah no it's it's a good question you
know to the extent we we need to be able
to spend money you know if we're going
to spend it out of this fund
obviously the bill would need to be
enacted and be effective before before
i think the best way i can answer that
is i think it's probably something we
need to think about and make sure that
we have thought we
we have this timeline in a form that
that is workable we have given that some
thought but
but i um
you know we have other ways at doj to to
bring in outside resources if we need to
through the litigation fund and i always
try to build some flexibility in there
we can reallocate resources internally
temporarily if we need to before we
perhaps bring in the additional
resources through this fund so we we
have ways to to address that but but we
will
i think for purposes of today what i
should say and commit to you is that
we'll
think about that further we'll take your
concerns uh into account and see whether
that we may need to adjust those
timelines again we're trying to balance
you know the need to have time to do
what we need to do logistically with the
desire to to move this right i mean you
state in here september is when people
or october can is when you can start to
accept
claimant or claims and that that's fine
but it just feels to me like you want
the effective date as soon as possible
right so that you you've got the money
spigot turned on so you can get ready
for october yep so so if you would think
i i had another question about the
contingency fees
contingency fees um are set up
if they just go through the
administrative process and 33 and
something percent if they uh go through
arbitration
and i saw where
if they go to arbitration
the um claimants attorney is responsible
for half of the arbitration costs
and i'm i'm just wondering if if that's
enough incentive for them
to be judicious in their use of the
arbitration route
because
i i'm a cynical individual
and and if somebody can get a
significant amount more money and they
think the arbitration route is more
generous than the administrative route i
i i don't see from an efficiency
perspective anything to keep people from
going the more laborious route of
arbitration so
are do you think these contingency fees
are set right do you think the penalties
are not penalties but the disincentives
to go to arbitration are set up right so
that we don't just have everything end
i think so i mean i think they're i
think they're they're set fine at least
for now i mean we can think about it
further but i'll give you my thought
process
the way the bill is drafted is that if
if you go to arbitration the claimant is
responsible for half of
the fees it could come out of their
award
but half of of any expenses of
arbitration
um you also could then be responsible
for even more attorneys fees because the
cap is higher and i i think
there's a there's just an inherent risk
in arbitration too i mean i don't
i'm not sure that
someone would go into this
being that confident that if they don't
accept
the the offer of the administrator
they're gonna get more in arbitration so
i think when you add up the the
additional cost to go and they're just
the risk that you'll get less
i think the incentive probably is is
is placed
is is well placed but but we can we can
think about that a little more just look
that's completely a legal culture
question that i'm i'm not qualified to
answer i just
am looking at it and wondering yeah yeah
i think to your point we wouldn't want
everyone just going to arbitration
because they figure i might as well go
to arbitration but i don't think this is
nothing to lose yeah um
okay so um
for a contingency fee for a system that
seems to be
fairly simple
to set up to get a settlement
just
sounds to me like maybe it's too rich we
had testimony in the hearing the other
day that says
suggested that claimants were deserving
more money
one way to get the claimant more money
is to reduce the contingency fees
so so how did we get to 25 and 33 and do
you still think those are the right
numbers
yeah so 20
for one i'll just say these are these
are caps so it's not necessarily saying
that this would be this would be an
automatic to you 25
the arbitrator can approve
or the administrator or arbitrator can
approve an award of fees up to 25 if you
don't go to arbitration and up to 33
if you go to arbitration so i think
that's the first important point those
are just those are not to exceed caps
i think that
we
you know we can't assume that someone
who comes through this process that
their attorney that they've engaged you
know was only engaged at the beginning
when they came through this process they
still may have done a lot of work before
they ever got to this process and i
think that that is potentially the case
with a lot of the victims that we see
represented by by council who appeared
last week
my my familiarity with these types of
agreements is that 25 percent 33
though that's not that doesn't sound
high to me that sounds pretty standard
and i you certainly see cases where you
have a contingency agreement and
you don't do much work at all and you
end but your client gets a large
recovery and you do very well yeah you
see other cases where it doesn't work
out as well that's the nature of
contingency i think that
we don't know what the terms are that
these particular victims have with their
lawyers that they've hired
but in the past
individuals who have brought forward
claims against the state for these types
of allegations
we've seen
fee agreements that have had percentages
that that look about in this range
so i
i completely agree with you that i'd
much rather see more of this money go to
the victims themselves but these numbers
don't strike me as being outside of
standard numbers okay thanks um
i'm now i'm looking at page four
uh in the area lines 24 through 28
the amount of time
that's reserved for arbitration
and it says an arbitration meeting can
last
no longer than three hours or can't be
scheduled for more than three hours but
it it gives the uh the arb the
arbitrator and the parties can make
additional submissions prior to the wait
that's not what i meant to say
it's
at the arbitration hearing the parties
may present additional evidence and
witnesses
and so i you know i'm just wondering
if um if we're maybe potentially
hamstringing the arbitrator if we say no
more than three hours and what's the
what's the point in putting the
three-hour limitation in there
i i think the point it kind of flows
from the intent of this to make this a
claims verification process and not a
overly adversarial process and so i
think
if this process is going to work that
way we wouldn't envision these hearings
needing to be longer than three hours i
will just look to attorney ramsey to see
if she has anything to add on that but
but i think it flows from that
that that concept that this is more of a
claims verification process than an
adversarial
arbitration
process is that right do you have
anything to add on that
okay
do you see any potential value in adding
a sunset
clause to this or or do you think when
we wind down the fun it'll this law will
just basically go away should or or
should we just sunset it so that it it
it dies on july 1 of 2032.
the law itself yeah
i guess that i think it would make sense
if the fund is going to go away on july
one on june 30th or june 30th yeah 2032
i think it makes sense for for this
statute to just be repealed at that
point as well so
yeah i think that would make sense okay
i because i'll probably forget by 2032
unless you
okay
i i think there are some provisions of
it that we might want to have okay
let's let's
let me let's think about that a little
bit okay fine fine um because i was
thinking you might need six months to
finish up all the paperwork too i don't
okay so so i think you all attempted to
address the right to know issue right
out of the gate and and i think the
why don't we just say
we're going to comply with the right to
know law
because i think
that would entail
parts of this process being open to the
public that would would not um
would not help us if we're trying to
to encourage a victim to come through
this process i
i know that there is a you know at the
end of the day even under 91a if there's
a privacy interest that outweighs the
public's interest in getting access to
information that that can keep something
from from being
being made public but needing to do that
analysis in every case and every part of
every proceeding i think would be very
burdensome i think of vic i think
victims would want to have some level of
certainty that at least certain parts of
this would be would be kept confidential
and i think
in my mind the public's interest in this
frankly how much money is being spent i
think
i would feel pretty safe in saying that
you know the victim's privacy interest
in some of the more sensitive details
would pretty much always outweigh the
public's
interest in seeing those details
so
to what extent
is there a public interest in the
details of the abuse itself
you know it it could potentially get
lurid
and so somewhere between lord and
academic
do you imagine
describing the nature of the abuse so
that people could look at that and go
i think that there would be some level
of reporting on that i think what it
would not but what we would not have is
the specific
instances or details tied to
a specific person yeah i don't think you
could prescribe that in advance but i it
just seems to me like that's part of
what you're reporting you need to think
through is how much is enough and how
much is
too too much and i think some of the
required reporting to the legislature
would would address that yeah
so are there other questions from the
committee from chairman emerit chairman
umberger
is there anyone in the
audience that
wants to say something this is a working
session and we're open
mr speaker you got any words of wisdom
for us
all right thank you for joining us today
thank you
i i think uh we will try to schedule
another um division iii meeting
before the 11th of february the 11th of
february the full finance committee
has
reserved an opportunity go go ahead
what do you what are you saying chairman
i i'm just trying to fall in line with
all right
so so can i use your time slot on the
11th of february then
and and because i presumably the room's
been reserved and we can just fall in on
that right
thank you um as i recall chairman
umberger invited the plaintiff's council
to redraft this bill and i wondered if
they had done so and if that was going
to be presented today well it's not
going to be presented today because
they're not there but but what i what i
heard the ag say and i i
i don't mean to speak for them is that
they have intentional stakeholder
meetings with those folks and that they
are working to collaborate
on
an agreed-upon position that could be
reflected in a potential amendment and i
suppose when they bring that a potential
amendment to us then the stakeholders
will be here is my hope
mr agee could you want to expand on that
yeah i think that's correct
representative i um the
plaintiff's counsel is they have not
provided a red line yet i think what in
discussing this with them what what we
thought would be most productive is that
they would start by providing that to us
and we'd sit down and see if we can get
to a consensus
product um
and
if we that would then be presented to
you so it would be sort of a joint
redline
it may be that we don't get there or we
agree on certain parts and they may come
and present other proposed revisions
that that we may not recommend but i
think
we thought it would be most productive
to start with them providing that to us
we can talk about it with them because
we haven't seen any proposed specific
proposed revisions yet and see if we can
see if we can at least get to consensus
on as much as possible before we come
back before you that way we can reduce
the
the multiple versions of different
sections of this that otherwise might be
flying around
and you're going to do all that by 7
february yep we're going to have a long
meeting on monday we'll we'll be having
a lot of discussion all right
are there any other questions did that
answer your question representative
walsh
thank you for the correction yes
absolutely
and and we've uh we've invited
representative long to also sit in with
us uh to provide some continuity with
representative rogers should she need it
so
are there are there any other questions
or no one in the audience left to speak
it's uh 2 23. uh we've gone on just uh
less than an hour and 25 minutes and uh
with that i'll close um this work
session on house bill 1677.
thank you thank you um now what we're
good so division one i think you're done
but i want to go ahead and recess for
until 2 30 which is about six minutes
so that people can come and go
and we can get ready
for
so
given that we ended the recess at 2 30
and it's 2 32
we'll go ahead and
open a working session
on uh
hb 103
fn
as amended
we have
representative joe shapiro to lead us
off do you want to give us your
yes for the record i am representative
joe shapiro representing cheshire
district 16 the city of keene
and thank you mr chairman and members of
the committee for allowing me to
introduce
house bill 103.
as you know this bill will establish a
dental benefit for all adult medicaid
recipients all adult medicaid recipients
providing them with preventive and
restorative services with the goal of
improving
the oral health of new hampshire's
neediest citizens
while hb 692 when signed into law by the
governor in 2019
created a dental benefit in theory
house bill 103 is a road map to
implementation
it takes the work done by the department
of health and human services working
group and articulates the scope of
services
and the model of delivery it also sets
clear guideposts going forward with a
specific date to put out rfps
for managed care companies a date to
apply for waivers from cms
and most significantly a day to actually
implement the program april 1
a very similar bill hb 250
passed the house and senate in 2020
unfortunately it was vetoed it should be
noted however that governor sununu in
his veto message
voiced his strong support for an adult
medicaid dental benefit and cited
predicted covet-related shortfalls at
that time as his reason for vetoing it
a work group within
health and human services committee
along with chairman edwards and staff
from dhhs worked hard this past fall to
create a dental benefit that would
satisfy those on both sides of the aisle
compromise led to concessions on both
sides
benefits were paired down and
co-payments were added
as currently amended house bill 103 will
provide diagnostic and preventive
services comprehensive restorative
treatments
medical necessary oral surgery
and remove removable prosthodontics or
dentures
only for the most vulnerable populations
cost sharing will be implemented to the
maximum extent allowed under cms
guidelines for those with family incomes
of over 100 of the federal poverty level
while a dental benefit will come with a
cost
you will see that over 70 percent will
be picked up by the federal government
and i had expected that there would be a
revised fiscal note but i understand
that that's not finalized
but i will leave it to the people from
department of health and human services
mr lippman and
dr finney to talk about the financial
picture
in addition we expect that a dental
benefit will result in significant cost
savings with improved oral health people
will be more likely
to become employed and no longer need
medicaid at all
expensive emergency department visits
will be reduced exacerbation of
co-morbid conditions such as diabetes
and heart disease will be reduced
lessening the need for extensive and
expensive medical care down the road
a dental benefit for adult medicaid
recipients has been a long time coming
it is significant step in improving the
oral health of our citizens
we have pared down benefits and added
cost sharing to encourage patients to
take responsibility for their health
care
with what some would refer to
as having skin in the game
it has been supported by republicans and
democrats alike house bill 103 as
amended was recommend ought to pass by
health and human services committee by a
19-1 vote
it passed the full house by nearly two
to one margin
we are getting close to making an adult
and full benefit a reality a reality
that will result in tens of thousands of
granite staters living with less pain
and more dignity
thank you and please vote ought to pass
when this bill comes to the full finance
committee
do you literally mean not to pass as
amended i do literally mean ought to
pass as amended okay
just to set up some context here
the fiscal committee
often
has has been viewed to defer completely
to the policy committee in terms of the
policy and that our job is
primarily predominantly to look at the
fiscal implications
i by agreement mutual agreement with the
chairman
he he has said that he thinks it's fine
if we look at
the policy issue as you know in a
rational way and and i've told him that
i think hhs ought to be considering
fiscal implications when it passes
policy so so we don't have a hard
firewall
um and with that uh i want to i want to
just touch on a couple of issues
in the bill itself um
on on on page one
line
five
are you with me
it'll take you a second is this on the
amendment or the actual bill it says as
amended so i believe this is um
the current version okay
and and this is also for dr finney i
believe um and
courtney what what was your last name
[Music]
okay thank you
um
so
so you all may have a role in
in resolving this
it says
that
restorative treatments for oral health
conditions
are less expensive than emergency care
and prevent oral conditions from
developing blah blah
so
i
want to just be really clear
we we asked in the working group
about the amount of money that we would
save on emergency care and it was really
a quite small number
and i just don't want to mislead anyone
with this statement
and so i'm just wondering if if
representative shapiro
and
ms morin and dr finney if
if if you think that
um if we deleted
the the words on line five
are less expensive than emergency care
and just delete that
so that we're not implying that that
are you following me representative
shapiro mr chairman i'm not finding
so so all i'm trying to do is is make
sure that our purpose statement is
precise and and fully accurate and as
written i i think it leaves the
implication
that we're we're going to be saving
money overall in this program by
reducing emergency dental care so so i'd
like to propose that we we delete the
words
are less expensive than emergency care
and
and just have it go
prevent oral conditions from developing
do you do you see what i'm saying do you
want to think about it or do you have a
response
i do see what you're saying and and
during our just earlier discussions in
our work group i think that the
amounts of money that would be saved um
as you said
did not seem very impressive um
however i think they were also very
i'm certainly willing to think about
this i don't think it's a big deal but i
i do think the general principle that um
people coming to the emergency room
that that care is much more expensive
than ongoing preventive care yes sir i
agree with you uh and i and i think the
rest of that sentence carries that
burden by by saying prevent oral
conditions developing into more complex
health conditions that would require
medical care the er is among the medical
care that we'd be preventing so i'd like
to just strip out those words about the
emergency room if if that's okay with
you and i'll give you time to think okay
i think i think at one point there was a
thought that we would save so much money
that this that this program wouldn't
really cost money because it would save
so much money elsewhere and that's
certainly not the case right right i i
think it turned out that
the savings on the emergency room were
approximately one-third of the
administrative costs of the program
which would make it kind of
insignificant but
uh all right so so then i'd like to move
on to the second item
and this maybe this is a dr fenney
question um but i'll let you guys uh
decide
uh it's on page two
line 23 and 24
and uh i i get what this paragraph is
doing and i'm okay with it i i i even
through smoking secession counseling
but then it goes and other services as
determined by the commissioner
and so i just want to make sure that
we're not
opening up a back door to expansion of
services without legislative approval
i would defer to dr finney on that one
okay
dr doc so you can sit where you are
sitting there representative and dr
finney and mr lipman we've got like
these intermediate tables if you want to
just go sit in one of those and have
and miss morin if you want you've got
i i think the first thing that i would
like to say about that classification of
treatment diagnostic and preventive
services
is limited in scope so when you look at
the coding that dental offices need to
use
to bill for services there is a very
specific and limited scope of
services that are included in those two
areas
so it's it's not
it's not a place where you could add say
more removable dentures or you couldn't
add root canal treatment there
because that is not restorative
i mean it's not diagnostic and
preventive
okay so you're saying the other services
is determined by the commissioner are
bound by the purpose of this paragraph
to limit it to diagnostic and preventive
dental services correct
do you agree with that mr lippman
i you know they're the experts on the
coding side but on the financial side i
think there's two other checkpoints one
is when we go for a budget allocation
and two um when we bring a contract
forward in terms of what's specified and
amounts with the governor and council
but i i
defer to the
folks across the table who are more
familiar with what the coding limitation
is so so i'm i'm happy with that that's
fine thank you thank you uh both uh
so
we're not going to start
paying for care until 1 april 23. the
effective date on on the last page
bottom
line says this effect this act shall
take effect upon its passage i i think
that's correct but have you guys thought
about this effective date is that
you know normally it's like 60 days
after the governor signs or
i think probably the language reflects
that it there's a in order to do this
right and get all the planning and go
for the waivers we need to be able to
start to act at pretty quickly
because there's a call for an rfi then
we have to do an rfp then we have to
actuarial studies i mean
there's a small window assuming this
ultimately got
passed
we have less than a year to implement it
and that's
there's a lot to be done it may not seem
like a lot but there is a lot to be done
so but if i'm not an expert on
the point that you're saying in terms of
legislative language i'd look to lba to
see if they have any um
suggestions there to tighten it up if
that's what you're feeling needs to be
done but yeah usually mr williams if he
has a problem with something he'll jump
on it but mr ripple do you have any
thoughts on the way the effective date
is laid out there i think the effective
date is okay for the reasons henry
mentioned there's a process that's being
put in place so it makes sense that that
would be the department would be able to
engage in that process immediately
the only thing i would say is section
three the appropriation on page three as
written that would be available
immediately as well even though it might
not be needed immediately
um but again i think henry might have
some commentary on how soon they would
need that money
all right
so i guess i guess i don't understand
what the advantage would be to waiting
i
it isn't an issue of advantage from my
perspective it's
an issue of what works for the
department and what works for the people
who have to go transcribe this and put
it into the rsas and stuff and that's
why mr williams will often times he's
the legal
you know miss williams
he'll often have a comment on the
effective date so we can ask him about
that yeah i i think i'm okay with it i
just i just wanted to check because it's
a little different
and and i forgot to ask uh mr lipman dr
finney and ms
marin to
introduce yourself for the record
sure
henry lipman state's medicaid director
i'm dr sarah finney i'm the state's
courtney morin actuary at northeast
delta dental i'm a fellow of the society
of actuaries and a member of the
american academy of actuaries
and you participated on our work group
that's correct yeah okay well uh uh
thank you and
representative irf i know i know you
have a few financial questions so why
actually i do have a bunch but that's
really what i want to get on to i just
wanted to touch on what you were
bringing up why not just take out the
word and other services as determined by
i guess there are times when there might
be a new
sealant or or something that could get
introduced clinically i think if if you
wanted to tighten it up i would suggest
as
as defined as
those uh preventative services as
professionally in the
the coding
of
i'm not sure what the dental american
academy of dental
something to that effect
i i i think what i would say speaking to
the the code set um every year the
american dental association reviews all
of the dental codes they have a code
committee a code maintenance committee
sometimes they delete codes sometimes
they add them and then sometimes they
amend them with the wording
and so that would be a situation but it
would be with any of the codes that you
know we might have to change something
based on the code set changing
is that a document or a location
enactment that could be referenced
absolutely yeah instead of just having
so if you if i could
if you wanted to vote by the
commissioner so the rules of engagement
today is we're having a conversation
colleagues talking to colleagues so just
if everyone's just polite to each other
then this will work out
could i get the spelling of the name for
the dentist
f-i-n-n-e
okay
thank you sarah with an h with an h yes
all right
so are you suggesting that
instead of listing the specific services
that there's just a reference to the
no so everything's fine up until and
other services as a term by the
commission rather than having that
clause if that could that clause could
just reference
this must be a specific
document that has these codes
specifically related to the diagnostic
and preventive dental services is that
accurate yes so that could just
identify that clause so i could actually
look at it and read it and say okay i
get what she's talking about right as
opposed to the way now look the way i
read this when i first read it i was
sorry but i was no i i understand your
concern and it's a good question it's a
very logical question but it's sort of
self-containing um i think what i would
suggest is that we could say um
and other services as determined by
annual updates of the cdt code set
that'd be great okay
and then you trailed off a little bit
did you imply that there would be a
range of codes that you would specify in
the legislation or
or you just refer to the overall uh
manual of the coverage
the um we refer to the overall code set
it's cdt which is the codes of
diagnostic terminology
and that is what has to be used um both
in private and public insurance in
claiming you know it's a consistent use
of codes for every single dentist yeah i
i it almost feels like that would
inadvertently make it more open to
discretion than just leaving it as is
because the overall code book has codes
beyond
the the dental
restoration and
if i understood correctly she's going to
reference the ones the code set related
to diagnostic and preventive dental
services
within that manual within that within
okay
so
so i'm surprised because i'm learning
something here is is the code book
so specific that there is a code book
that only deals with diagnostic and
preventive dental services
i would think that that code book has
a vast range of oral procedures okay let
me give you a quick
rundown on the cdt codes
they they start with 0
100 numbers
then one thousand two thousand three
thousand four thousand five thousand six
thousand each of those thousands is a
different category of service
and so we can be very specific
and assign one subset of the code set to
each of these areas in the bill so let's
do that
okay
so now if i might doesn't have another
question for doctor you you can keep
going you're on a roll
for representative i'm sorry
um and this relax relates not yet this
is still about your testimony i i
thought you referenced
uh
2019 law chapter law 3 4 three four six
two two
five is that did i understand correctly
you actually brought that up because i
have a question yeah well okay
you kind of referenced it in the light
of oh this is expanding upon that i
think we should explicitly amend this
bill to
repeal that
because i actually went and read that
and it's a whole different
approach to this
i think what that what that bill did is
it actually
removed the prohibition
of having an adult benefit
it has date specific when it should be
in effect and that date was a a year or
more ago
so i just think we should repeal that
as part of this somewhere i'm sure mr uh
uh ripple could
come up that amendment to justice so
that's gone and this will be the bill
that
or the law
that defines the uh
medicaid dental benefit does that make
sense
if you really want to keep going i will
but that was really okay
now i gotta
so while you're doing that mr ripple are
you catching all these notes so you
could uh put together a draft amendment
for the committee i have so far i think
the only thing that i'm not quite clear
on is the diagnostic and preventive
dental services so
that would read and other services as
determined by i didn't catch the last
part
so dr finney
could you just
uh send a quick email the way you would
phrase it and and what the number range
is that you're referring to to mr ripple
yes
and i guess my other question um with
eliminating the old april 1 2021
requirement that was in the trailer
build from 2019 would you want me to
repeal
that entire provision or only the april
i'd like you to repeal the whole thing
okay
does that get rid of the work group
it would get rid of the previous work
group but i believe the bill
before you house bill 103 would have the
i don't think it mentions a work group
it mentions reporting now okay
so actually yes you're correct that
would get rid of the work group is the
work group just a subsection of that
chapter
could that just that one subsection be
left and repeal the other bits because
it actually does i only read it today i
didn't really great detail but it seemed
to describe an actual program
it did
i think the program piece would be good
to remove so there's not two sets of
programs in law i think the
the allowance of a dental benefit and
the work group
maintaining those things are important
whether
they get re
recodified or remain
as you suggested as a possibility
okay i'm happy either way as long as the
program is not
there i just do not want to see the work
group be removed because that's been a
huge piece of us getting to this point
and there's been a very wide array of
stakeholders from around the state that
have been involved in that and i i don't
want to see that go away i think we need
that moving forward don't want to kill
that
so i think in that case
the 29
2019 trailer bill said it established
the working group then it went on to say
the adult dental benefit shall become
effective on april 1st 2021. each plan
shall include at a minimum a detailed
description of the following and it went
on to say what the proposed plan should
include
i could
each plan shall include
until the end of that section so the
and remove everything from the adult
dental benefit shall become effective on
april 1st 2021 through the end of that
section and this might be easier if you
could see what i'm reading too so if
you'd like i could print this out and
i can see it but if the rest wanted that
would be helpful to me okay let me know
what you're doing
do you want us to recess for five
minutes so you can do that is that what
you're thinking sure okay um
so uh we're going to stand in recess
it's 2 58 now we'll reconvene at 3.05
of okay
let um get their own choppers right
no
how many of them ask for no no
not to be thrown out and quit paying
rent
courtney
do you do you participate in auburn's
deliberative sessions do you go in and
they're kind of interesting
yeah they're sort of
run like many legislatures
where you know warrants and stuff get
debated and
people propose amendments and it's sort
of interesting
never seen anything like it i've lived
in a lot of different places i've never
the town basically forms its own general
that's what they do in many other
countries
but
we've
it was a very snowy day when i first
pulled in
because i didn't i didn't know anything
about new hampshire snow and it snowed
like two feet
my driveway it was
just packed
got stuck
that's great
welcome to new hampshire you're stuck in
we had been living in a suburb of
rochester new york and um our daughters
had both gotten far enough through the
college process that we knew they were
and
it was it was one of those mcmansion
things where
i i kind of realized we had to move
somewhere
when i was walking through the house and
i noticed that there was a room with a
piano and a nice couch and we were
calling it the dog room because only the
dogs would go in there
right
and and they weren't going to learn how
to play the piano so i thought you know
part of this is really wasteful
so we just bought a a house we bought on
rattlesnake was just meant to be for my
made us you know
pardon me like with a pasaki rattlesnake
or uh no no no no just we're of the
so do you have a stuffed rattlesnake
no they claim that there was a mill
along a river
yeah that you know and there was a lot
of sawdust and stuff and people claimed
that there were rattlesnakes in the
under that mill
ralph's
rare
in the mud or in the weeds
well
joe's been
kevin was
doing stuff in there he was just having
so we're going to stay on recess until
and i say that because we're still being
recorded
well i just looked at 692. it's in there
and it was signed right
there is the repeal i think just want to
make sure that they're repealing the old
one that they don't repeal the appeal
right
but we're only talking about
revealing something from house bill 4
not from 692. i think 692 was actually
replaced by houseboat oh okay paying
attention
yeah
forward because there was an agreement
on the budget and
then that was subsequently handled so i
think you left me a voicemail saying uh
our auto pay number was uh declined
it's 0 8 25.
kevin
i think it i think
in 692 it explicitly said it repealed it
i mean it's used
but in this one it just says that it
will create an adult
the first full sentence which ends right
there
pages
yes all right so
the working session on hb 103 fn is uh
is now back in session
so
handed us all a paper
uh do you do you want to talk through
this what what you want us to see on
here uh yup this is just a portion of
the trailer bill from 2019 and on the
first page which is page 77 starting on
line seven
you can see the provisions that relate
to the dental benefit and the working
group that initially would have
established it and that goes on to the
next page on line 13. so i think the
question is what which aspect of this
you want to repeal in the current
bill
i think the two things that we want to
shall develop a plan for the
incorporation of an adult dental benefit
establishing an adult dental benefit and
so so what to say it differently uh what
lines
representative shapiro do you see us
deleting
and after
page 26
okay
so
what representative earth is is
mentioning is lines 7 through 11
to be eliminated
and then go down to line 26
and after 91a
from that sentence down the rest of the
page
and the next page
and that same section should be
eliminated
so i i gotta admit i'm confused i
seeing what is there now
so i'll say what i i think we're wanting
to do we're and then anyone can correct
me
we want on page 77
to start deleting from line seven
all the way through line 11.
then we want to drop
down to line 26
afterwards says rsa 91a
we want to begin deleting the department
in consultation with the working group
shall
and then
that all gets deleted from that point
through line 36.
then when we go to page 78
we are deleting
lines 1 through 13.
one two okay
so we'll keep the reports so everything
mr ripple yep
is 346 colon 226 part of the same 2019
get deleted i would think that we might
want to keep
um
line seven eight and nine up to the word
platform on
line nine
because that's really
language from that bill which is
established are you on page 77 or 17 77
okay
okay so you're right
seven through 11. yes up to the word
platf
up till after the word platform so on
line nine right
so you recommend keeping lines seven
eight and nine through the word platform
just because that's the language that
establishes an adult dental benefit
so
repetitious
it's repetitious in what way um
representative weiler it's
in the new bill
okay because we're about to try to pass
a new bill
we're saying that this is no longer
needed
do you how do you respond to that
i mean we are trying to pass the bill
right i guess this won't go through
unless the bill gets passed so right so
if we don't pass the bill in this states
right
i'm just worried about losing that um
repealing the prohibition about
about not having an adult benefit but
this
this will not be included this will not
happen unless the bill goes through in
his past so i think that would be fine
okay
dr finney do you do you agree do you
have
this can be a little confusing jumping
around like this are you tracking and
sorry
it was originally
meant to be in value-based care
and that is
stated in the current
um legislation yeah i could have sworn i
read value-based care in hb 103.
right so we're good that's that was the
only thing that you're happy then i'm
just after it's sort of put together
just like to run it by john williams to
make sure
i like to run it by john williams after
we pull something together in final form
yes sir
so so mr ripple just just so we're we're
tracking would you would you tell us
what what we you think we just said
about page 77 and 78 yep so i think on
page 77 uh we would remove lines 7
through 11. obviously that would
necessitate renumbering and also ols
might want to come up with a new uh
section name for what would be the new
225 but effectively you would remove the
substance of lines 7 through 11.
and then on page 78
would you go down the rest of the page
because we still think you're at 27. yep
uh from line 26 through the end of the
page
everything that begins with the
department in consultation with the
working group yes okay and then what and
you would delete lines 1 through 13. yes
all right
so i
i think we're in agreement
on what we think we're going to do and
we stipulate that the department will
have an opportunity to run it by mr
williams
thank you
all right
uh so we'll we'll do that before we send
it over to ols so so kevin i i forget
your your process when you work on
amendments
you work directly with ols don't you so
they would end up having to come up with
a
an ols version of an amendment
like right away that's that's how you
work and then we'd get that amendment
over to mr lippman for mr williams
review yep we could do that we should
have one available at some point
tomorrow for the department and
everybody on the committee to take a
look at
okay
all right so going back to the scene of
the crime representative erf do you
still have questions
yes thank you mr chairman i have my real
questions
so i'm glad we have the
um oh my goodness
miss
what's your function again actually
actually thank you that's really who i
wanted to talk to
so i'm assuming you're the one that came
up with the cost estimates
i am not the cost estimates that you see
are from an outside actuarial firm i did
review their preliminary estimates
though so i couldn't is your microphone
on because yes we're trying to broadcast
is that better
so i did not come up with these
these estimates that you see these were
done by an outside actuarial firm
i have reviewed their work when they
presented to the work group
so i i feel um
i can answer some of the questions about
the cost estimates but really dr finney
and mr lipman would be might be better
but we can all close well here's my
question then actually it's even easier
than that can we get a copy of that
the work that was done by the outside
group
yes yes that's what i really really
would like to see that kind of possible
normally you like the spreadsheet i
think it's just a simple little thing
i think the the
the confusion is that
department of health and human services
uses an outside um consultant
actuarial
called millerman is that correct yes
and they do they do the actuarial you
know estimates
right and i mean gonna understand that
i'm assuming it's more complete than
just this little spreadsheet
that is very similar to the spreadsheet
from two years ago
except especially from two years ago had
a little bit more detail so i'm seeing
what this actually did was something
that will give me a real idea of how you
got to these numbers because now that
these numbers they seem very low
i'm not like to be able to compare them
i would just say that you'll you'll see
a difference definitely between the
medicaid population and a normal plant
population especially given how limited
some of these benefits are
so
i'll just offer that
northeast delta dental did do some
pricing on our own just to compare and
came up with very similar numbers to
what millman had come up with
so
though you might want to take it and
compare it to to a
regular group insurance
rate you're not going to find similar
numbers there
okay so help me understand why it would
be a lot lower for the medicaid
population
the
first the benefits are very limited in a
normal plan you're going to have crowns
covered for example and those aren't
going to be covered in this
in this uh benefit offering
um and second there's just there's
there's differences as well there's
pent-up demand for all these people that
have not yet had benefits that are going
to go in and use the plan
there's also
transportation extra transportation
costs have been built in there's
differences in benefit maximums there's
just
it's not quite comparing an apple and an
orange but you know you could look at it
that way that they're they're still
fruit but they're they're different um
okay so first of all transportation was
separate so i get that
but second of all when you say that they
haven't had dental dental service in a
while that tends to drive up costs not
drive them down
so i'd expect things to even be higher
i would be curious about if you're if
delta dental is a good comparison i'd be
curious to see your plans as well then
to compare them because i know in my
case dental plans cover pretty much
cleanings two a year and that's pretty
much it on top of that you're paying
hundreds or more dollars
and certainly crowns aren't included in
my plans my wife's plan actually so i
just like to see the actual you know
what you're actually coming up with
because i think the numbers just looking
at them they seem very low that's all
i can certainly share estimates that
okay but
fine that'd be great but then can you
compare them to the can explain to me
because you just use general population
versus this population but what i heard
you say was in the medicaid population
it was more expensive to get them on
track so to speak so i'd like to have
you unders i'd like to understand right
now but i have to understand how you
think it's less expensive than the
a population like us like me
i'll i'll just i'll try to offer
something quickly and if this doesn't
answer it we can i can certainly try to
provide more but in a normal employer
paid plan or employer-based plan the
coverage is going to be 180 50. so
that's going to cover 100 on diagnostic
prevent those cleanings that you talked
about
80 on restorative basic restorative so
so things like fillings or um root
canals are sometimes included in that
category oral surgery and then 50 on
services such as crowns or implants or
other things
and of course orthodontic orthodontic
could also be covered supplementally
this
keep going could be
not always but could be um so and
you said
often you have to go in and it might be
a couple hundred dollars well a typical
crown could cost a hundred excuse me a
thousand to twelve hundred dollars so if
it's covered at fifty percent yes
even as an employer sponsored plan it
could be covered you still would be
paying out of pocket a significant
amount
most often plans are going to cover
major services as well a typical
employer-based plan the most common
employer-based group insurance plan does
in fact cover major services and
typically those are covered at 50
so percent
you just send me the plans that probably
the easiest thing for me to look at
because i know you're a dental person as
opposed to a general purpose sort of
insurance person and
and i think it'd be good to i don't
think most
maybe i'm wrong i certainly know some
corporate plans don't cover like you're
describing
yours covers which is great but just let
me have the plan so i can compare them
i think i think that the actuarial for
the department did um estimates based
exactly on the way the amendment was
written and what services there would be
so i think
we should get you whatever information
um
they have because that's a that's a
match to the
um amended plan um
so that you know that that's what their
cost estimates will be based on that
would be great if i could just
i wouldn't have to go i don't know
so i i did want to say two things i
think one is
the professional fee schedule that goes
along with a commercial plan is higher
we did make an allowance
the actuary did and the actuary for
millamon was someone who practices in
the dental space it wasn't just a
general actuary they did have general
actuary support but they had someone
that
specifically deals with dental
so there is a provision to because
medicaid dentist participation this plan
is only going to work if dentists
participate right now there's a very
limited network of dentists that will
participate so the the cost that you're
seeing here also includes
an upgrade to the fee schedule for the
dentist
and then i will just add on to that that
it's important to understand that
medicaid programs in general across the
country
do not pay at the same rates as
commercial insurance we're usually at a
percentage of commercial and so that's
i understand that is the goal
but when you say
you have to get actual dentists correct
in new hampshire that will do the
services for lower part and in the
medical world
that's driven by forcing hospitals to
accept lower rates
basically in the dental world i don't
know you have that same leverage do you
so that's where i think the work group
was important in terms of
practicing dentists and and others in
the
field
in terms of what was
a more normative
level of reimbursement that would expect
to enlist it and that's also where
a firm like delta dental who has a
network can
have a better chance of
enrolling dentists because they do
business more broadly you know the same
could be true of another
vendor as well but i'm just saying that
that's i think
um
that's where the transportation came in
as well because the dentist and the care
management that goes with that
as the dentist said you know i don't
mind doing
um
services for medicaid but what i do mind
is when i have a chair time and no one
shows up and so it's dealing with that
no-show rate is part of what is built
into the program here and i think that's
what dentists were looking for in the
work group
it wasn't just about reimbursement there
were other support mechanisms that would
allow them to consider taking uh
medicaid
i do understand that and you and you
very nicely kept the transportation out
so i understand that that is a separate
cost and i'm not questioning that at all
i was just looking at the dental
um cost and i guess i'll be curious to
know that you know the list of dentists
that agreed to these rates that's all
right
i think the the other thing that i just
wanted to mention and i'm sorry to go
back again to the categories of service
but
um you will see that um it's very
difficult to
compare two plans unless you really look
into the specifics of what categories of
service are included in each one
because that accounts for some of the
the cost difference
one of the things that we tried to
achieve with this benefit designed the
way that it is
was to take care of the disease that was
going on in
a member's mouth
but not necessarily
fix that with
fixed crown and bridge work
that you can make a choice between
having teeth taken out and then replaced
with removable dentures
and so it's it's this weighing of doing
what you need to do to be able to place
fillings and also to extract teeth to
get patients back to a healthy state
and then
you know replace teeth in those
populations that are included to have
dentures and those are all the ways that
you know as you look at each iteration
of the cost estimate we put something in
to see what it did to the cost we would
take something out but it was all
ultimately based on the conversations
that occurred at the work group
between not only you know dentists and
hygienists but
other stakeholders and what was really
important for the folks that they
represented
when i talked to my dentist about this
bill um he's um
he's a dentist who does take
um medicaid and also does a lot of work
with local
private nonprofits
you know he was
he was quick to tell me all the problems
that there would be with this
new benefit
including the difficulty of collecting
co-payments in his office and having
people understand those
and that the medicaid rates will be too
low
at the same time he said all those
things he was
absolutely overjoyed that there would be
that
that this would just give care to so
many people and would
decrease unreimbursed care in his office
so i would say that it doesn't fix
everything
um
but it's a great um
it's not just a start it's um it's a
great improvement
i i don't question that your plan is a
great improvement at all my concern is
the cost estimates that that's the part
i'm
this is sort of what we do here
is are these costs and if you just give
me the information so i can look at it
that would be very helpful there just
wasn't enough in the financial note to
really get an idea where the 25
a month you know figure came from that's
all i'm asking i understood i think that
i have confidence in the work that the
actuary did and i think we have a chance
to share it with you and go over it with
you
and get you to a point where you're
comfortable i think we're comfortable
that if that was the budget we had to
work with we could work within it
super thank you i do have one statistic
that might help significantly i hope
um the standard
the average reimbursement as a
percentage of private insurance as
calculated by the ada
was 56 percent in the state of new
hampshire so on average in new hampshire
the medicaid rate is 56 percent of what
the private insurers are paying
so that right there speaks to what henry
was saying about the price discrepancy
and the fees
so that would bring the cost down
significantly
because that's all that's being allowed
to the dentists
when you said the medicaid you talked
about
care
no the dent the dental medicaid right
there are you know there's a children's
program in place now and you mean the
mco that currently does it that's what
you're referring to yes no wait no the
mcos do not cover yes one of them
doesn't benefit
i think in the adult dental area if
somebody's been hurt in a car accident
and needs some moral care because of
trauma that medicaid can pay for that
isn't that part of current
yes
hold on a second
i'll make sure we're talking about the
same thing so there are three mcos in
new hampshire that do medicaid one of
them has a full dental plan no no it's
not a full dose one of them has a dental
plan and that's only for adults
yeah yes
i just want to make sure that we
understand the children's benefit is a
comprehensive benefit that is you know
required by cms
that is a fee for service plan that the
state manages
it's not provided by
the mcos
this plan isn't for children only is it
i think we're completing things here
there's a there's a i think when you
were referring to the 56 we're referring
to the fees that are in the children's
program that's one
that's one concept and so those are the
fees that would exist today
if we did nothing else in the in the
adult space exactly
that's that's sort of point one
point
two
um
the
uh merit health
is offering
a very limited dental benefit that's
much narrower than even what we
described here and i think that the per
member per month costs
are considerably lower um
i think
i i i'm going to throw out a figure that
i'd want to verify but i think we're
talking about five dollar kind of range
per member per month um
you know
the america health plan has that lower
which makes sense it's a lower
there it's right we're not the state's
not paying for it they're taking that
out of their administrative load and
they're doing that because they're a new
entrant to the market to try to build up
market share and they have built up a
pretty good market share they're
they're
the third largest plan but they have
so i think that addresses all my
questions in that in that realm
representative
oh i'm sorry i thought you were done no
i'm just warming up here this is
actually i think for you um mr whitman
so we just talked about the amera health
plan do you know what
value-added benefits of any that are
dental related the other two mcos offer
they might be something like an oral kit
like that they might provide on an
annual basis that might be
toothbrushes and
dental floss and that kind of thing but
there's no there's no
provider that they can go to to get
and i guess the last question is just
regarding the appropriation
just like i said why is that it's a
pretty and i realize it's not an annual
it's not enough to cover the annual
appropriation but it's a fairly
significant sum of money for a program
that's not even starting in terms of
starting some cash until 2024.
so
um i think there
there's been
since that the original um
going back to hb4 and the derivatives of
different uh looks at this benefit the
state
managed care program we've historically
had a lag in what we paid for premiums
and the the value of that was sort of
just
cash but i think in more recently
starting
in 21
um fiscal year we've we've gone to a
standpoint of
being if you will current on premiums
and and effectively what we're doing is
buying cash flow from
and given this the
governor's perspective on
making payments since we also have to
recognize the cost whether we pay them
or not in our our comprehensive
financial report annually it just made
sense from an economic standpoint to be
current in our premiums as opposed to
arrears and so what we propose to do is
to have the dental program consistent
with how we're running the rest of
managed care which is on a more current
basis
and that way if we started in april of
23 we would need that appropriation
available to us to
make premium payments
yeah rick
alluding back to something that mr
lippman pointed out
too many medicaid patients are
unreliable at keeping appointments
i'm tempted to say
we ought to have a co-pay you miss your
appointment you pay us five dollars um
cms does not allow us to do that that's
uh rule so we never would address the
unreliability of medicaid patients i i
heard from one person whose practice was
he didn't even make appointments he just
looked out in the waiting room people
needed help came to him came to the
waiting room and waited i think we do
address it in other ways
that's one of the reasons why
we spent a lot of time discussing care
coordination and having support from
employees of the dental vendor that
would work with
members to give them support to find out
why is it you're missing your
appointments
they're unreliable people that's why
there are extenuating circumstances
at times and i think that
we
if we're going to invest in these
programs we need to look at the reasons
why
people behave in certain ways and try to
support them so that they can become
healthier so
to
address your question as i understand it
you
you would propose and maybe we can do
this in future legislation you would
propose some kind of a penalty for a
missed appointment so that there's an
incentive to not miss appointments
what we have done
that i think is new a new new thing
is the department has gone
to check to see that we could get a
waiver so that we could start to charge
some co-pays for the people who come in
and actually receive their services
and dr finney is suggesting that
we
ought to um also try to be managing
no-shows by providing kind of the
wrap-around services to help make sure
they're able to
uh have the transportation and get
get get there now now i i think between
our best efforts
and
the inherent unreliability of some of
the population
i think we're always going to have some
no-shows i think that's just the cost of
doing business and and maybe we can get
some stats on that in the future and see
if there's a smart way of addressing it
what i heard her say was that
cms wouldn't allow us to charge for no
shows
did you say that
and my dentist if i don't show up would
charge me
okay i i didn't hear dr finney say that
my i apologize
i was listening i would agree with you
that it is really a big problem
that you know having had a
private practice psychotherapy practice
for years and take and i took medicaid
um it was a real problem
for me and more importantly for the
treatment when people didn't show up and
and i think there is
a certain extent it's a stereotype but
um people whose lives people who are
poorer and people whose lives are more
disorganized
probably have a higher um no-show rate
than other people so
i would agree with you that it's a
problem and i think we're trying to
address it in a positive way by giving
um
by supporting people to actually get
there and um
and we also have a a reporting aspect to
this bill where people will where the
department will have to report on
various statistics and i think that
would be one of the things that would be
important to report about
um at the end of the year so we can um
try to remedy that if
if it's uh obstacle to the whole program
working
one of the the major principles in a
value-based plan
is that
the vendor shows that the providers are
making improvements year over year
and one of those improvements is to make
sure that patients are coming in for the
care that they need
but i think what we've realized is it's
not always possible for the dental
provider
to really have any effect on
the
patient and so we're looking to have the
vendor be a part of that solution that
they're giving support and it's not just
for the dental treatment because this is
going to run over into medical costs in
certain situations so it behooves the
vendor
to really work with the state and also
the providers to improve patient health
year after year
your follow-up
thank you for the discussion
okay so
i do i have another question and then i
have a theory so let's just do the
theory first i i i'm actually kind of
optimistic that we're not going to
um
run into some big numbers initially on
pent-up demand and and part of it's for
a good reason because when emeritus
started their dental program
um
i think they experienced some adverse
selection and so
so i think they burnt up
some of the pent-up demand by
you know the adverse selection aspect of
them
opening
the doors and then the other thing is i
i keep hearing
or
and this maybe you could clarify this
we're expecting that initially there's
not going to be
a fully flushed out network of providers
and if and if we don't have a flushed
out
flushed out number of providers then we
have a rate limiting step to how many
pent-up demand people can show up just
because
you know there's no room at the end
so so those are just theories i i don't
know if you want to comment on any of
that
if i could comment i think that
it could be true but i want we made an
allowance if it didn't happen if the pot
if the
optimistic if you will in terms of a
cost standpoint right um
we have provided a factor in here to
assume that it would be pent up demand
but i think it's realistic given what's
going on in society in general in terms
of medical appointment dental
appointments that you know the
depending on how long
um you know we're dealing with the coven
situation that is there's a backup and
availability and it would you know
provide some relief so i didn't mean
anything actionable by that i just
wanted to convince representative
shapiro that i think about this other
than when he calls me
so
and and maybe this is a question for mr
ripple i'm looking at page
whatever the first page of the fiscal
note
and i'm seeing the 1.7 million in fy 22.
and i'm i'm just
i'm a little confused by that should
should that 1.7
instead of being an fy20 do find itself
an fy23 uh we put that there because the
act is effective upon passage so
it would be effective this fiscal year
but but as i read it it's money that
sounds like it's going to pay for
for dental care because it says 1.39 to
fund the benefit for traditional
medicaid population and 337.5
to fund the benefit for the expanded so
so that sounds like dental
reimbursements and and we're not
going to treat our first patient until
april 1 of 23. i i agree with that and
the program obviously wouldn't be up and
running until 23. uh we just put it
until we just put it in 22 because since
the act is effective upon passions the
department would have the money
available to it immediately even though
it wouldn't be spent until the next year
okay i i will defer to you because
you're the lba expert
what representative
if you wanted to you could actually put
that into the bill but the way it's
written it basically takes effect upon
the date that section that portions it
doesn't say a different date
it could have a different effectiveness
if you wanted to you know i i like all
the dates that is written i i just am
just curious why the 1.7 ends up in an
earlier
fiscal year than what i think the
expenditure will actually take place
so
we can't spend anything practically
until we have procured a contract and
that's going to be a while yes
it's not going to be before june 30
right and that's the definition of the
end of fy22 yeah i mean we'll we'll i
think we don't even issue an rfi until
august of
this year and then go through uh an rfp
and then a contract procurement i think
it's
so so mr ripple i'll i'll defer to you
as we're amending this if if that's
something that should be uh changed or
modified i'll leave it to you to
determine that i think
i i think it's okay as written because
as a practical matter the department
wouldn't actually spend the money until
23 however you could solve the problem
by as representative earth suggested
just having a different effective date
isn't the effective date fairly quick
take as soon as it gets passed which
allows uh the department to be unleashed
to start issuing rfis and all that stuff
so so i i i kind of like you know
letting them get going but but you don't
put the first patient into the chair
until april 1 of 23.
and i think i think sections one and two
could continue to be effective upon
passage you wouldn't necessarily have to
change that you would only change the
effective date for section three so that
the appropriation wouldn't actually be
available to the department until fiscal
year 23.
we'd be fine with that if that's
technically correct right
yeah i i just keep thinking of these as
public documents and i'd like them to be
accurate so that the layman could pick
it up and kind of see what's going on so
we have have different effective dates
for different parts of the bill yep i
think uh sections one and two would be
effective upon passage that's currently
written and section three could be
effective july first
uh 2022.
that'd be great that'd be great
representative walner representative
rogers representative bean what do you
think you have questions for us you got
you want to make us smarter somehow
no
we've got a couple lobbyists in the back
do you
you've observed this all afternoon what
do you think do you guys want to say
anything you want the opportunity to
make a statement
no
um
all right so what i think we're going to
do is we're going to have
dr finney you're you're writing up a
snippet
so that we know what code range is
relevant and and you're going to send
that to mr ripple
mr ripple's taken everything else he's
heard and he's going to create an
amendment
that amendment
will come to obviously us but we need to
get it to mr lippman so that mr williams
can do his sanity check on it
and so uh so i'm just trying to think
um
can
if we say that we'll meet again on this
the first or excuse me the 11th of
february which is when we're going to
hear 1677 again
it feels to me like we could have a very
short meeting if that amendment meets
everyone's purposes
will it also be acted upon by the whole
finance committee on that day
the finance committee was going
i don't want to say all that uh the
finance committee is planning to meet
after the 11th of february okay so we're
releasing it from the subcommittee
process to the finance to have its exact
session
so then i had earlier gotten a notice
for the 11th for an exec session that'll
be postponed
that that will be postponed and in its
place
this working group will meet
so
chairman umberger gave us her time slot
for us to meet again
and then she has to go reschedule
okay
all right any last words representative
shapiro this is your baby how you
feeling
looks good i think we're getting there
okay
i just have sorry i just have one more
question about the amendment before you
wrap up
um
on page one
line five did you decide to take out the
phrase are less expensive than emergency
care and i didn't i don't recall the
conclusion
yes sir
we're just going to delete that because
uh after the the phrase oral health
conditions
starting back up with prevent oral
health or
prevent oral conditions
the
everything we need to say is covered by
the rest of that anyways okay thanks all
right thank you for asking mr lippman in
terms of handling the request of
representative erf is that something i
could work directly with him on that's
an excellent question that's still to
do's so um
how do you want to handle that mr uh
ripple do you do you want mr lipman and
uh to work just directly with
representative erf until he's satisfied
no that would be fine i would just ask
if you could copy me on any information
that you provide
invite you to a call yeah
thanks
do it together
okay good catch thank you
i would like to thank uh representative
rogers um for coming and participating
in both of these i i
what what time is the meeting on the
11th
it's gonna have to be put into the
calendar i i'm going from memory i think
so so just to get it said uh while i can
say it i i think your participation is
oh
um
grandmother